valentine's day has made it really a
busy night at local restaurants so many
have been booked up now for weeks and
it's really a positive sign of change
after months of uncertainty because some
had trouble staying actually hiring
full-time people madison kimbrough is
live just off the strip with how they're
rebounding tonight madison
we're here at ferraro's italian
restaurant in wine bar where they say
business is booming and this valentine's
day being fully staffed is crucial
valentine's day is in full swing as
restaurants kicked it into high gear all
weekend long to accommodate couples from
all around and with staffing shortages a
problem for some that's not the case
over at ferraro's italian restaurant and
wine bar we are
busy we have over 600 reservations on
the books which is
is close to record
but we've had some bigger nights so
we've had some practice with this but
owner mimo ferraro says a couple months
back was a different story and while he
feels like the omicron variant played a
role in the shortages he also has seen
more and more workers just leaving the
restaurant industry all together people
not wanting to work has been one of our
biggest challenges trying to hire people
same sentiment over at modern american
restaurant sparrow and wolf owner brian
howard explains the problem for us was
finding more staff to compete with the
business levels
we're busier than we ever have been so
we needed to increase our staff by
another like five percent luckily though
on this valentine's day howard and his
crew have found their way back and even
plan to fully open back up come
mid-march we're ready it's time to get
back open to seven days and you know we
have the staff levels to do it
both restaurants also mentioned that
with the recent mask mandate lifted
they're prepared to be even busier
reporting live madison kimbrough live
local now